і порушено перемир'я на сході України
дали більше іван і стають чим далі
грубішими че хочеш за гали боку
конфлікту досягнуто політичного
компромісу та меру
я на ces по подаюсь alla yak розколи та
сторони конфлікту так близько одна так
одна секція у вигляді altitude вузлів пивних
ділянок лінії розмежування
то режим profi мене у вогню на жаль
пастей але порушити епоху терезів та сенге
b1 постріл частоті на за собою порушення
перемир'я
завдання з простріленої місії зруби ти
всі мацали вошивість ситуація a list of a
сохнута спецціна
попий sound as we той ще кращий доступ
маються постере хоче приборкуємо ви даєте
розділи ти сторони конфлікту та лев
примати
штати менші за машканти на сході україна
раз повідає щоку лис постере гочі йдуть
то підпорядковується стріляли на за крима в
ночі через сцену кіно фарбує їх нічно
встатку вати з пасторальну місію
продовжить і годину cool edit буваєте
процес розуміння щоб заруби ти всім
url його
для устремління primary test on the gear
head
про що ви може розрубати ще б спливуть
і на сторони конфлікту та smooth цієї їх
до пори мерія ощадному труп у нас
мало малого коштує для тес клуб ми можемо
випробувати з творить і атмосферу давиш
відпалював однією проблемою всього
конфліктує ще до вірус руну на а6
україни українська сторона травня ж зовсім
обидва зовсім на довіряючи русі
Росія ж часто ви слова ллються про т.ч.
як нам євросоюзу не потреби
добросусідський вид носа не знаю ми хочемо
біля лапок чуючи
ви рішення від усього конфлікту аум луна
без їжі psy держави з'єднувати заводи
столом у тому числі росія найкраще ще
можна труби ТЕЦ-2 рідина випробувати і
повернені в витрачання треба віру та цілі
основою для співу проти срубає і перший
коло з кітніс там потанин і в тому авто
перший мусою початий рух на зу stretch
of тому я до нас просуну за себе вперед
середні україни
навіщо з правді хочемо ще коридорі
відривалася а ваш кейс бро і не було вигляд
вейдена а бік конфлікту краще
розмажу wanna to потрібно обожнювання об бок
старовина в тему конфлікту in conflict алли
також потрібно у чистих то біля хвиля
рішення в наклепі Москви кипить рибу і
і т.д.
франк-вальтер штайнмайєр розмова з приводу
я голову нічого без я проти чудову
роботу е п внизу будки ситуація сьогодні
вже прощання було
ми з пробуємо про продовжити ці маленькі
рук та пальців від сексу